now joining us in the studio is the
former Education Secretary Michael Gove
hello thank you for being with us now
owning before we start I'm keen to get
your thoughts as someone who's still
someone very well connected with lots of
people in the cabinet Jeremy Hunt health
secretary hasn't tweeted for five days
he hasn't been seen in front of a camera
since those NHS cyberattacks do you
think it's okay yes I absolutely I'm not
Jeremy was actually in Cobra yesterday
helping to coordinate the response to
the cyber attacks as health secretary he
has that managerial responsibility and
last week I saw Jeremy on the Robert
Peston program we appeared together and
he was unveiling a very exciting and
important mental health initiative
Jeremy's been and will be an absolutely
superb health secretary and I think that
he's a real asset to this country into
the government so why hasn't he been
anywhere since this huge very worrying
cyber attack because he's a hands-on
health secretary and it will be his
responsibility when he's discharging
very well to deal with the situation
that arose but because it's a crime was
also appropriate that amber rod
explained what the steps are as Home
Secretary responsible for dealing with
crime in order to try to make sure that
the people responsible for this attack
are actually tracked down and dealt with
fair enough hands off health secretary
perhaps hands and all hands off slightly
when it comes to the media hands on when
it comes to dealing with the attacks
that putting management of the health
service first is the single most
important thing that any health
secretary would do I know from my time
in government that sometimes there would
be a request from the media that you
might want to accept in order to appear
but your first priority was to get
things right in your own department to
talk to those people who were
responsible for delivering services and
to make sure that patients or in my case
parents and pupils came first now the
big policy announcement from the
Conservative Party today is this pledge
to build more council homes is this
another example of Theresa May stealing
from the Ed Miliband paper no I don't
think so we had Alex Salmond on earlier
speaking from his increasingly marginal
seat in Scotland talking about what he
termed a hard right Tory government the
truth as your question implies is very
different Teresa may and her team occupy
the mainstream middle ground of British
politics and one of the difficulties
that we've had in the past is that
labour in power
didn't build the number of homes
including the number of homes for rent
that we needed and Teresa is intervening
in order to ensure that ordinary working
people have the chance not only to have
a home to rent but in due course our
home to buy as well now you say that
Teresa most government is all about the
kind of middle ground
some people would dispute that when it
comes to brexit which of course is you
know the big one of the big issues of
this election to Reason a promising to
take the UK out of the EU after the
single market you must be delighted as
someone who was in that vote leave
campaign because she seems to swallowed
your playbook well I am very pleased
that Teresa may is taking Britain out of
the European Union and I think whether
people voted to leave or to remain and
of course I respect the strong and
idealistic sentiment but motivated many
people to remain the question in this
election is who do you want across that
table from jean-claude Juncker do you
want to resume providing strong and
stable leadership or do you want Jeremy
Corbyn we've already seen Jeremy Corbyn
during the course of this general
election campaign short out a series of
nonsensical policies he would be a
disaster as Britain's representative in
those talks so whatever you want from
brexit I personally do want us outside
the single market and outside the
customs union whatever you want juries
amaze the person best equipped to
deliver it because I wonder if you ever
have a moment of doubt or concern about
that because the war words between
number 10 and Brussels does seem to be
intensifying to resume effectively
accusing Brussels of meddling in the
election and this is what the foreign
secretary Boris Johnson said yesterday
they're going to play dirty they're
going to try and bleed this country
white with their bill do you agree with
Boris Johnson that the ear we're going
to try and bleed this country white I
think it is the case that the EU will
put have put quite a big price tag on
our departure that's part of negotiation
and if you want the best outcome for it
and then you need to have a tough
negotiator teresa has been described in
the past
indeed on Sky News by Ken Clark as a
bloody difficult woman and Teresa has
actually turned that phrase round and
said what you need is someone who will
be difficult and determined on Britain's
behalf in those negotiations and that's
why I think at this election we can't
afford to take the risk of having anyone
else other than Teresa mayor's our prime
do you accept
we will have to pay some money because
Boss Johnson seemed to apply that is the
EU you should be paying us to leave
there's absolutely no need for us in law
to pay money as we leave now the final
details of this negotiation will be up
for the prime minister and for the
cabinet to agree but in law the House of
Lords have spelt out in an authoritative
report that there is no need for us to
pay a penny when we leave and whatever
happens once we've left it will be clear
that we will be able to take back
control of the money that we currently
give to the European Union hundreds of
millions of pounds a week now we've been
talking about Boris Johnson there I
think it's fair to say a few eyebrows
were raised in Europe when he was made
foreign secretary
last year you famously described Boris
Johnson saying he cannot provide the
leadership for the task ahead you
comfortable with him playing a role in
the negotiations yes I am last year of
course during the the tumult of
leadership election I put myself forward
and we ran operate very well and
therefore by implication I was saying
that I thought that I was better
equipped than Teresa may I've now had a
chance over the course of the last 11
months or so to look at how Boris and
Teresa have performed in their
respective roles I think Teresa has got
every major decision right as Prime
Minister and I think Boris has been an
asset to the country and to the
government as foreign secretary I think
on facing down Russia over its behavior
in Syria in making sure that we forged
strong relationships with the new
American administration and also in
ensuring that international development
money and Britain's soft power is
playing a part in helping to reconstruct
Africa and those nations which have been
broken by external events he has shown a
strong leadership role and it's also the
case that having someone who was a
hugely popular champion of the vote
leave movement there at the heart of
government well I think that's something
that is all to the good David Cameron
someone else who we've seen out and
about on the campaign trail this week
let's have a look what he said about not
very coded message this perhaps for
tourism oh it's so important that the
Conservatives win and win well so
Theresa can stand up to people who want
an extreme brexit and he said
here and elsewhere so he's talked about
people like you isn't he people who want
a hard brexit out of the single market
key brexit ears does treasom a need a
big majority so she can stand up to some
of those pesky brexit ears i think she
she deserves his strong majority so that
her hand can be strengthened in dealing
with brussels but speaking for myself i
don't know whether or not i'm oh are
hard soft or any other type of breakfast
here all i believe in is honoring the
mandate that the british people voted
for and during the course of that
referendum campaign those of us were
arguing that we should leave so the
really important things that we take
back control of our borders of our laws
of our money and of the ability to make
our own trade deals and resume in the
speech that she gave at Lancaster House
brilliant speech earlier this year said
that Britain was going to do just that
so for that reason I strongly support
Teresa in these negotiations and as
Prime Minister and I do agree with David
that the stronger her hand the better
the deal that you'll be able to secure
for Britain when was the last time you
spoke to David Cameron a while back well
how long is a while back month well one
of the things about private
conversations is that they're generally
always better kept private so on this
occasion and Dave is no longer in
politics and therefore I will respect
his privacy by by not talking about that
do you miss him I think David was no
standing Prime Minister but I also think
that Teresa has shown not quite the
question I asked with respect no no no
but I think the thing is that a if I'm
think if one thinks about politics David
did an amazing job as prime minister he
ensure that we had a conservative
majority and a friend serve as a
fabulous team essen well I think again
I'll respect the privacy of that
relationship because I think that
palpable in what people in this election
wants to focus on I hope are those
candidates who are putting themselves
forward and the ideas that they have so
of course I look back with respect and I
feel enormous affection and respect for
David Cameron as an individual and as a
politician but a new chapter is opening
in that chapter is one in which we're
deciding whether or not we wanted to
resume to have a strengthened hand and a
stronger majority and I think and I
agree with David here that the stronger
her maturity the better it will be for
this country
now you've been very
loud and clear in this interview with
your praise for Teresa mayor you're
clearly a fan of the work she's doing do
you think she's doing a better job than
you would have done if you'd been
elected oh yes you do
why is that well I think that you know
the proof of the pudding is in the
eating
the the demonstration of the way in
which Teresa has made all the major
calls on brexit successfully the obvious
popularity that she enjoys the stability
and strength that she's brought to that
role
all of these reflect incredibly well on
her judgment and her leadership
abilities and so all I can do is take a
step back and admire the way in which
she has on the economy on education and
on Europe showing a degree of
consistency and clarity as leader
there's something else as well during my
leadership run brief as it was one of
the things that I tried to articulate
was the need for the Conservatives to do
more for people on average and below
average incomes and actually to be fair
Teresa she was on to this issue before
me and she's delivered on this issue far
more energetically I think than anyone
could have expected any conservative
leader could have done and the result of
that focus on ordinary working families
has been popularity in the polls but
also a conservative party bringing
forward proposals including on areas
like new council housing but reflect the
interests of the overwhelming majority
now you know any person in your
household unflinching in their support
of Teresa mayor your wife wrote a column
saves backing up her idea of boys and
girls jobs in the house so you do do
carry acne boys jobs quickly what's your
jobs in the house yes I do what I'm told
I'm in in in our home much as in the
country I'm very very happy that a
strong woman is in charge
very sensible answer there Michael Gove
thank you very much for coming on the
show thank you